et voit loin c'est vrai on voit loin
m'ouvre bâton ça reste définitivement
très très étrange
une théorie qui nous explique que les
extraterrestres aurait commencé à nous
visiter à partir du moment où nous avons
atteint le niveau technologique
suffisant pour déclencher une
catastrophe nucléaire la vie ailleurs et
des temps visage
les extraterrestres ont réussi
l'incroyable et même impensable exploits
du voyage interstellaire
ils sont parvenus à franchir dessins des
lumières de distance
en revanche point de vue pilotage ils
font des conneries comme nous irons pays
au volant il ouvre des créneaux et de
temps en temps il se viande
les gens n'ont pas le temps pour
grossistes la flore ci dessous comme
wallace et efficace
je tiens ma voisine est lumière non non
non non non non parce que là le type à
l'intérieur du cockpit
ils passent directement du compte à
rebours elle est à gaz on fait tout juan
ignacio a en a perdu l'envié
m